[Applaus]
am hauptsitz des internationalen komitee
vom roten kreuz in genf herrscht reger
betrieb
ein hoher gast aus der europäischen
union stadtpräsident peter maurer einen
besuch ab alles ist bereit
wir sind zu früh oder genau richtig
zum glück haben wir den turbo eingelegt
na ja keine fahne aufgehängt
ja das ist gut dass wieder die von der
uno oder unsere eigene nein die von der
uno wir haben nur zwei hier haben wir
die schweizer die genfer und die
französische aber die wird neu gemacht
dass genf sitz zahlreicher
internationaler organisationen ist ist
für das ikk ein vorteil nicht nur
humanitäre gemeinschaft gespräche führe
sondern dass man tätig sprach von
politisch wichtige persönlichkeit ist
eigentlich eine banalität aber
unabhängig und neutral ich um anita
reaktion gibt es nur als politische
unterstützung für gegeben
in der vorhergehenden folge erfuhr
stéphanie lr das in syrien ikk kollegen
als geiseln genommen wurden in kolumbien
wurde abraham bloß abend dem
freundeskreis jäh unterbrochen
eine attacke forderte einen
schwerverletzten nadine besuchte in
kabul eine schneiderei deren chefin
kämpft mutig für die unternehmerische
unabhängigkeit in goma gelang es dem ikk
einen jungen mann zu seiner familie
zurück zu bringen
nach sechs monaten der ungewissheit ist
die freude groß
[Musik]
am hauptsitz trifft eu
kommissionspräsident josé manuel barroso
ein
es ist eine große freude sie beim ikk
begrüßen zu dürfen
was für ein schöner tag wir haben den
richtigen zeitpunkt gewählt
wie alle wichtigen besucher trägt sich
auch barroso in das goldene gästebuch
ein
er lobte die exzellente zusammenarbeit
auf der traktandenliste der sitzung ist
die lage in syrien und in der
zentralafrikanischen republik
ich freue mich wirklich sehr dass sie
das ikk besuchen
zum ersten mal die sitzungen ist
vertraulich
[Musik]
in kolumbien sind abraham tobago und
sein team wieder unterwegs
heute will er einen workshop für eine
umherstreifenden bewaffnete gruppe
machen
mitten im dschungel
das ist eine herausforderung denn hier
kämpfen rebellen milizen und kriminelle
banden um die vormacht es geht um
drogenhandel bodenschätze und viel geld
auch abrahams team wurde schon zur
zielscheibe
[Musik]
team war auf dem fluss unterwegs und
einen betrunkenen feierte etwas um 10
uhr früh er war mitglied einer
bewaffneten gruppe dann fielen schüsse
eine kugel schlug nur etwa 70 meter vom
tatort entfernt ein
wir versuchen das risiko gering zu
halten
aber es gehört zum job wenn ich ins feld
gehe denke ich nicht ständig daran sonst
würde ich es nicht tun
meine eltern vertrauen darauf dass ich
vorsichtig bin und nicht mein leben aufs
spiel setze bei der ankunft im dorf ist
alles ruhig
die einwohner haben sich in die häuser
zurückgezogen
wir wissen die bewaffnete gruppe
beobachtet uns
[Musik]
am hauptsitz ist die stimmung aufgerollt
das ikrk ist eng mit der eu verbunden
auch finanziell
die europäische union und ihre
mitgliedstaaten sind wichtige geldgeber
nach den gesprächen steht eine
pressekonferenz an
die journalisten wollen mehr über den
verbleib der geiseln in syrien wissen
gibt es fragen john vom verlauf von 11 p
nur kurz haben sie neuigkeiten zu den
entführungsopfern im moment leider nicht
mehr arbeiten daran und hoffen auf eine
möglichst baldige befreiung
dann altbayerischen schon zum nächsten
termin
prima dann gute reise nach brüssel wir
bleiben in kontakt dankeschön ich habe
das sehr geschätzt und am sonntag ein
kurzer aber bedeutsamer besuch und
vollendet von der europäischen union
oder vorträge selber und das ist
natürlich roger heidt wortlaut frage
miteinander sprechen
gegenseitige erwartungen und
möglichkeiten klar aber das ist nicht
das fundraising event wenn die
präsidenten der europäischen kommission
nach ganz unten ist das prima
symbolisieren das mittägliche richtig
ziehe das unheimliche lektüre haifa das
nächste problem sind
und dass man die politischen
unterstützung von der europäischen union
helfe das was wir machen
[Musik]
die delegierte stéphanie lr macht heute
keine gefangenen besuche sie will ihre
kollegen in der westbank begleiten
so fährt sie aus dem pulsierenden tel
aviv hinaus in das palästinensische
autonomiegebiet bald 70 jahren schwelt
der konflikt zwischen juden und arabern
um den legitimen anspruch des landes die
westbank wird vom israelischen militär
kontrolliert
palästinenser haben eingeschränkte
bewegungsfreiheit und eingeschränkte
wasser und nahrungsmittelversorgung
in nablus im norden der westbank
besuchen wir mit dem fehlt officer und
der delegierten eine familie
ich bin mit dem fall noch nicht vertraut
wir dokumentieren anschuldigungen von
übergriffen oder verletzungen der rechte
von zivilisten an die adresse der edf
der israelischen armee oder der
jüdischen siedler
sie trifft die ikrk-delegation in lich
menschenrechtsorganisationen prangern an
dass palästinenser immer wieder
unrechtmäßig festgenommen
festgehalten und verurteilt werden
aquilani ist fehlt officer er fährt mit
dem team nach uri
dort ereignete sich ein zwischenfall
zwischen palästinensern und dem
israelischen militär
mit dabei ist auch die japanische
delegierte mit kawasaki griff ist
umgeben von jüdischen siedlungen und
sperrzonen des israelischen militärs
konflikte sind programmiert
rehm aquilani erklärt stefanie die
aktuelle situation vor ort
[Applaus]
die siedlungen sind auf dieser seite
dort wurde ein bulldozer steht dort auch
die schule steht dort dringen die siege
von außen ein auch vom osten
sie greifen das dorf werfen steine gegen
die schule überfallen häuser ich
erinnere mich an zahlreiche
zwischenfälle in diesem gebiet wo
bulldozer und autos angezündet worden
wie viele siedler gibt es hier weniger
als 1000 weniger als 1000 aber sie
breiten sich aus ja sie haben
verschiedene außenposten und schwärmen
von da aus
das team will nun im büro des
dorfvorstehers vorwürfe von jungen
palästinensern gegen das israelische
militär anhören wir sind in goma
die stadt liegt nahe der grenze zu
ruanda und uganda immer wieder kommt es
zu ethnischen konflikten und
kriegshandlungen nachziehen plündernde
banditen durch die straßen
hier im flüchtlingslager findet man
vertriebene opfer von
massenvergewaltigungen und überfällen
die lebensbedingungen sind elend weil
wir grenzen sind schlagen immer wieder
granaten von bewaffneten gruppen aus
ruanda ein verletzter zivilisten
soldaten und milizen werden im spital
behandelt das ikk hat es zu einem krieg
spital umfunktioniert und bildet hier
einheimisches personal aus
pflegefachfrau brigitta hat ihre stelle
im inselspital werben gegen koma
eingetauscht für ein halbes jahr
das habe sie immer schon gewollt sagt
sie
die maschine ist du auch viel mit den
krücken geht es gut
im februar hier mit der schussverletzung
im weg sagt im flüchtlingslager ganz
noch im koma und ich denn im februar vor
rebellen flüchtlingslager das ist schon
ihr hobby nfr tsx v mmy achse mit einer
riesen wunder gehofft mit infiziert mit
immer wieder im ob es mit einer
möglichkeit der probieren ich habe ganz
oft in decken amputieren und eigentlich
vom ersten tag aber immer guten mutes
dringend im bett hat zeichnet wie
verrückt und gibt sich leider ist es
mein buch cent und mich hier keine
maulwürfe und die ccb ticker die zwei
freunde zum glück noch nicht machen
hallo stehst du auf jetzt zeigen wir wie
gut du schon gehen kannst kommen sie zu
mir
[Musik]
es hat das geht gut bist du zufrieden
das ist so schmerzhaft mit deiner
verletzung einer bombe von einem
splitter das wasser wie viele
oberflächliche wurden ergibt und das
aufsplitten im beijinger blieben
verständlich oder granat völlig neue und
unbekannte risiken kriegsverletzungen
ja was schwierig ist und wo mir raushole
dort wird für die kinder darauf die die
leute die müssen solitär der die ganze
theater unter der die konflikte
susi die jüngste hat nur knapp überlebt
die g2 oder geht's gut sagte vorwoche
ich sehe mit der ganzen familie morgen
hoch xi bombay schlager hätte muss und
wir stehen verletzung im thorax herz
thorax waren 238 und das ist der fall
bei menicon ist sicherheitslage
amerikanische hier und sehe ich jetzt da
und geld eher gut und ich finde weder
uns noch nie
in halo normales lexikon sloot und ist
extrem quick video und rennt oma im
nordwesten kolumbiens und einem geheimen
ort mitten im dschungel erklärt eine
pflegefachfrau aus abram dorados team
basiswissen über den menschlichen körper
entscheidend ist dass ihr versteht da
ist diese organe lebenswichtig sind
wir werden nun die anatomie unseres
körpers erklären die schüler sind
mitglieder einer bewaffneten
umherziehenden gruppe nach langen
gesprächen dürfen wir sie anonymisiert
filmen
der jüngste ist 17-jährig der älteste 28
schießereien und gewalt gehören für sie
zum alltag
hier lernen sie wie man ein bein ab
findet und wie mund-zu-mund-beatmung
funktioniert vielleicht werden sie das
schon bald anwenden müssen
für abraham ist dieser kontakt
existenziell
je bekannter das ikk ist umso besser ist
es geschützt vor überfällen und
angriffen
darüber hinaus erhält abraham zugang zu
gebieten in die sich keine andere
humanitäre organisation wagt und er hat
kontakt zu der dorfbevölkerung die oft
von bewaffneten drangsaliert wird das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
beschäftigt sich mit konflikten und ganz
wichtig es gibt regeln während eines
konfliktes zb einen verletzten kämpfer
muss man pflegen ihn behandeln
das ist eine regel verschwindet jemand
hat die familie ein recht zu wissen wo
die leiche ist
sie haben ein recht auf die übergabe der
sterblichen überreste
und respektiert das ikk bitte einer der
männer erzählt wie seine kollegen ums
leben kommen viele viele sind in unseren
armen gestorben
viele wir sind mitten in einer
schießerei in einem kampf
es hagelt mörsergranaten handgranaten
sprengkörper wir sind dem tod immer sehr
nahe
der tod ist immer unter uns ungeachtet
der taten der gruppe das ika kart bleibt
neutral unabhängig und unparteiisch
der kurs ist für uns mittel zum zweck
er ermöglicht uns allgemein gültige
regeln aufzuzeigen die die anerkennung
der medizinischen mission oder der
umgang mit verschwundenen familien haben
das recht zu erfahren was mit ihren
angehörigen geschehen ist minenräumung
das rekrutieren von minderjährigen
sexuelle gewalt gegen frauen
das alles wird an diesem workshop
thematisiert das unterfangen bleibt es
kommt dieses mal ist alles gut gegangen
[Musik]
in der westbank begleitet der familiäre
charakter kollegen diese drei jungen
palästinenser beschuldigen das
israelische militär gewaltsamer
übergriffe das ikea will die vorwürfe
anhören
sie ist hier um mehr über unsere arbeit
zu erfahren
rebecca downie übersetzt um 17 uhr kamen
fünf siedler
sie waren maskiert dann sei das ibf das
israelische militär vorgefahren und habe
sofort tränengas und gummischrot
eingesetzt
30 personen die sich draußen versammelt
hatten wichen in die häuser zurück
auch hier zählt seine verletzungen auf
an der rechten hand
zwei an der linken hand am arm wurde er
von einer tränengas patrone getroffen
und an der linken schulter und an der
seite er sei hingefallen und habe sich
nicht mehr bewegen können erzählt mahmud
dann habe man ihn in handschellen gelegt
innerhalb von drei tagen sei er in vier
verschiedene gefängnisse gebracht worden
sollen wir hier oder in seiner wohnung
weiterfahren
vielleicht sollte er uns erzählen was
nach seiner verhaftung geschah aber es
wäre wohl besser das gespräch bei ihm zu
hause wartete finden
ja ich finde das auch besser es ist eine
längere geschichte das team begleitet
mahmud nach hause und will mehr details
zum fall wissen
[Musik]
wir sind in golbach 80 km nördlich von
kabul
es ist eine grüne fruchtbare gegend hier
wütete der krieg während vieler jahre
nadine der direktor des orthopädie
zentrums in kabul ist auf stippvisite
bei seinem berufskollegen das ikk
betreibt acht solcher zentren im land
viele menschen tragen prothesen
sie haben durch den krieg oder durch
unfälle glieder verloren
[Musik]
matschie modin trägt selber zwei
beinprothesen beim anblick eines
patienten kann er nicht anders als
sofort sein wissen und seine erfahrung
weiterzugeben
vor 26 jahren habe ich genau mit diesen
job hier angefangen
ich liebte es jemanden zu zeigen wie er
wieder gehen kann
winzige veränderungen machten ihr leben
so viel einfacher
seitdem kämpft er unermüdlich für
bessere lebensbedingungen von
behinderten
dann lädt uns mit ihnen ging zu seinem
vater im pandschir tal zu begleiten
[Musik]
zurück nach kuba ins krieg spital ist
ihnen noch schwindlig nein sehr gut
nehmen sie das mit im spital lösen sich
die frontlinien des krieges auf
schwierig mehr wissen der patienten
kennen sich natürlich das opfer und
setzt jetzt wie hier im raum vielleicht
ein anleger sehr viel ich kenne aus dem
kampfgebiet sich viele aus den
verschiedensten dürfen können
vielleicht fängt sie unter die
verschiedensten ecken und friis ist es
somit probiere der mensch leser warum es
aus ihrer herkunft im sinne der
philosophie eine einfach so behandle job
machen sie die therapie mit der flasche
sehr gut
peters weise mit der atmung
der krise sorge sind sie eine
schlagershow schlosser worte ich nichts
wenn es im rücken lungendurchschuss ist
nach rom eine ziemlich kritische zustand
zum sexy baby männer paraplegiker und
zwei tage rückt ganz schlecht zu stoff
braucht
ich bin zufrieden es geht schon viel
besser aber es braucht geduld haben wir
ja das stimmt
das kommt ja aber du musst jeden tag die
übungen machen ja danke die akustik
kommen context for conflict die romane
es gebe etwa woche ihr geht und und wo
sieht jahre so unruhig aber nur die
ersten zwei teile zerschnitten schicksal
und das sehe und die gewalt war hier
herrscht das nackte frau mit patienten
und angehörigen war amputiert worden und
das hat mir möglich sogar einen moment
lang tsv weniger sonst die behörden der
schweiz der männer uni spital wo alles
möglich ist wo man macht als eigentlich
möglich ist für mich empfehlen
hier hat die gesellschaft mit
[Musik]
in der westbank folgen stéphanie lr und
das egal car team dem palästinenser
mahmud in dessen haus die ganze familie
ist als ältester bruder heißt sie
willkommen waren die handschellen aus
plastik oder metall
ja ja sie waren aus plastik er war schon
verletzt musste aber immer noch
handschellen tragen
fotos aus dem spital sollen die spuren
der auseinandersetzungen dokumentieren
verletzungen am kopf und der schulter
und am bauch der linke arm ist gebrochen
der junge mann sieht sich als
unschuldiges opfer israelischer
militärgewalt tränengas und
gummigeschosse seien aus zu geringer
distanz eingesetzt worden
seine verhaftung sei widerrechtlich
gewesen und es habe zu lange gedauert
bisher medizinische hilfe bekommen habe
die soldaten befahlen ihm sich auf den
boden zu legen zwei stunden im team nein
nicht im jeep auf dem boden neben den
jeep auf den boden bevor er zum militär
camp gebracht wurde lage auf den ohren
fährt zwei stunden auf dem rücken
das sagt er zwei stunden seine augen
waren verbunden aber er trug keine
handschellen mehr
wenn er angst hat es können wir den fall
auch anonymisiert beschreiben
ich bin einverstanden es ist okay die
behörden kennen die geschichte er hat
nichts dagegen seinen namen zu nennen
mit udo kommentiert mahmud aussagen beim
nächsten treffen mit dem israelischen
militär wird sie den fall besprechen
sollten sich die vorwürfe erhärten gibt
es eine untersuchung im umgekehrten fall
bei beschwerden von israelischen
soldaten gegenüber palästinensern macht
das kkh dasselbe
[Musik]
putin ist unterwegs ins pandschir tal
das ist seine heimat mit dieser gegend
verbinden ihn viele erinnerungen
in diesem tal bin ich aufgewachsen hier
habe ich die schule bis zur achten
klasse besucht und bin danach gaben
gegangen ich war 15 sich weg
aber ich kam oft zurück
das ist das tor zum pandschir tal
überall erinnern bilder an ahmad schah
massud den volkshelden der 2001 getötet
wurde
er stammt von hier
als teenager hatte ich oft brennholz von
diesem berg auf der anderen seite des
flusses
ich habe das gefühl ich kenne jeden
stein überall bin ich entlang gegangen
all diese bäume in den bergen ich würde
so gerne noch einmal dorthin gehen aber
das ist leider unmöglich
ja
[Musik]
als kind bin ich jeweils vom dorf wie er
zur schule gegangen
es gab sonst keine andere schwule zehn
jahre lang belagerten sowjet truppen das
land noch immer zeugen verrostete panzer
von deren präsenz ahmad schah massud war
maßgeblich an der vertreibung der
belagerer beteiligt danach führte massud
den afghanischen widerstand gegen die
taliban an
2001 vor 13 jahren viele einem attentat
zum opfer
mit ihm sei auch die hoffnung der
bevölkerung auf veränderungen gestorben
hört man hier das ist mein haus ich gehe
mal nachschauen
nadines vater bittet uns freundlich
hinein
[Musik]
nach dem besuch des eu
kommissionspräsidenten barroso hob ist
peter maurer in eile
bald geht die maschine nach brüssel
danach fliegt er in die usa
fürs backen bleibe ihm gerade 20 minuten
ist das logistische herausforderung das
muss ich sage also vor der topdeq zu
derartigen dass sie gar nicht brauchen
das sieht europa brauche
wie sieht da hat die pole
tausende in die sau begleiter nehmen die
weko vor beiden mit und das mini frau
war hilft und das macht eine wg und für
alle neu bezogenen tun ist auch ich von
der evonik griechische sehr gut mit
tonic
und das mittagessen fällt bei mora oft
aus genuss sei aber durchaus wichtig
versichert er
als kritische organ gut das unternehmen
eigentlich nur mehr wenig stimmig also
im usa
wenn irgendwas doch hier in ganz wien
und im schlaf
der name mir eigentlich
folgender bisschen roboter sommer legt
aber und das ist das ist nicht wichtig
andere und die habe ich zum beispiel
situation vor offizieller natur an in
ihre freude messen
dann wird sie aber noch will kann hier
ja aber das ist nicht der etwa nachteile
position ist aber schwer mit kollegen
zusammen ist die familie war nicht
unbedingt das kritisch bei der aktion
die tasche das ist heute den job nicht
machen
das ist
dann geht es schleunigst ab zum
flughafen
[Musik]
stefanie ist zurück in tel aviv die
westbank scheint weit weg
kommst du aus amerika nein wissen was
ich wissen was schweiz zweiter schweiz
wieviel willst du ein kino ein halbes
kilo
wie heißt du stefanie ich heiße dalli
dalli da genug genug spricht arabisch ja
ich spreche ramisch das leben in tel
aviv ist entspannt die atmosphäre
tolerant und weltlich im gegensatz zum
übrigen land hallo liebe wie geht es dir
bist du immer noch am strand
ok bleibt ihr noch 20 minuten weil das
leben hier einige vorzüge bietet wird
sie von kollegen aus der westbank
neckisch strand delegierte genannt das
leben hier ist sehr angenehm
manchmal fühle ich mich fast ein wenig
schuldig es gibt einen so starken
kontrast zur arbeit die wir machen wenn
man die meiste zeit im gefängnis oder in
befragungs zentrum verbringt und dann
nach tel aviv zurückkommt tel aviv es
eine blase vom konflikt kriegt man hier
rein gar nichts mit
wir sind zurück im pandschir tal
[Musik]
nadine der in kabul wohnt bis zu besuch
bei seinem vater
mit 18 jahren verlor ich beide beine bei
einer minenexplosion das zu akzeptieren
ist für einen selbst schwierig aber für
die familie ist das auch sehr tragisch
besonders für die eltern bei mir sowieso
weil ich der älteste sohn bin
sie hatten große erwartungen an mich
sie waren mit einem mal zerstört während
fünf jahren saß ich zu hause ohne
aufgabe ich erinnere mich dass ich
mehrmals zu behörden ging nach arbeit
fragte sie sagten
wie kannst du nach einem job fragen ohne
beine
ich war schockiert
das problem war ich konnte ihnen nicht
mal zeigen dass das möglich ist
sie gaben mir keine chance anders das
ikrk es gab ihn prothesen eine
ausbildung eine karriere etwas konnte es
ihm nicht geben
ich erinnere mich und es tut weh ich bin
immer wieder in diesem fluss geschwommen
es ist so schön so gut im august
glasklares wasser
tiefblau kalt leider geht das nicht mehr
wie oft hin und her geschwungen
das gefühl des wassers fehlt mir
die neffen freuen sich über den besuch
des onkels manchmal hangeln sie mit mir
[Musik]
diese treppen sind schwierig für mich
etwas scheu leitungsnetz putins vater
ein die nacht in seinem haus zu
verbringen
doch wir müssen zurück nach kabul in der
nächsten folge erklärt nacho den krieg
ski roden worauf es bei einer amputation
ankommt
abraham ermahnt das kolumbianische
militär die genfer konventionen
einzuhalten
stefanie l erbringt in gaza einer
blinden mutter ein wenig licht in ihren
alltag und präsident maurer setzt sich
auf höchster ebene für besseren schutz
von zivilisten ein
[Musik]